alors que le trafic reprend dans le
canal de suez l'heure des comptes le
porte-conteneurs qui est bloquée pendant
une semaine
cet axe maritime cruciale entre l'asie
et l'europe a mis en lumière la
fragilité du commerce mondial alors
comment un tel accident incident plutôt
peut-il engendré des milliards de
dollars de pertes que nous dit il de
l'évolution du commerce international
c'est l'objet de l'édito rico ce soir
mais bon soir jacques sapir quelle
histoire donc ce bateau qui bloqua le
canal de suez c'est quand même plus fort
que la sardine du port de marseille je
sais que c'était une blague pour le
premier avis mais je la lis quand même
mon cher jacques oui tout à fait bon
soir stéphanie absolument à écouter oui
c'était un très gros poisson on peut
lire un poisson qui est même resté au
travers de la gorge du commerce mondial
puisqu'il a bloqué à peu près de 12 % du
trafic mondial
alors bon bien sûr le navire a été
dégagée au début de cette semaine mais
il faut quand même savoir que chaque
jour où il a été bloqué ça a coûté aux
armateurs l'équivalent de 8 milliards de
dollars
autrement dit en trois jours un point de
croissance de la france c'est bien il
nous sommes tout à fait extraordinaire
et ça prouve bien effectivement une
certaine forme de fragilité du commerce
international
essayer d'y voir plus clair jacques rs
commencé un peu plus sur ce qui s'est
passé
oui tout à fait alors il semble bien que
ce navire et qui est un navire
d'ailleurs tout à fait moderne mais il a
été livré en 2018
ce navire a été déséquilibré par une
rafale de vent extrêmement important
peut-être y at-il eu une erreur humaine
c'est ce que disent les égyptiens mais
ce n'est pas confirmé et donc ce navire
est allé percuter la berge du canal
alors il faut savoir que s'agit d'un
monstre des mers et on se rappelle
évidemment de cette image qui avait
beaucoup circulé
vous voyez une petit tractopelle qui
essayait de dégager ce navire il fait
400 mètres de long il jauge comme on dit
plus de deux cent mille tonneaux
autrement dit il est pratiquement deux
fois plus gros que le plus gros des
porte-avions nucléaire américain
actuellement en service et donc on était
bien là en présence d'un accident tout à
fait extraordinaire qui a bloqué cette
partie du canal qui se trouve entre port
saïd et ismaïlia autrement dit sur la
portion de canal qui n'a pas été encore
modernisée par le gouvernement égyptien
on sait que le gouvernement égyptien à
engager des travaux extrêmement
importants
il a agrandi le canal sur une portion
qui est plus au nord mais ils ne
l'avaient pas encore fait sur cette
portion là alors effectivement ça a été
un blocage d'environ six jours et sur
ses six jours et bien les armateurs ont
perdu 55 milliards de dollars
alors est ce que cela signifie que le
canal de suez reste la jugulaire de
l'économie mondiale non parce que il
faut aussi prévoir le trafic qui passe
par le canal de suez a baissé en
proportion il a augmenté en volume
global mais il a baissé en proportion
et il ne représente plus à peu près que
12 à 13% après ce que ça montre c'est
qu'il y à bien toute une série de points
de passage qui sont des points de
passage obligé dans le commerce maritime
alors évidemment les deux grands canaux
1 le canal de suez et le canal de panama
mais il ya aussi des détroits des
détroits qui pourrait être bloqué par un
accident voire par une volonté mal
intentionnés deux puissances régionales
et de ce point de vue là si on connaît
bien le détroit d'ormuz l'assemblée avec
tous les problèmes qu'il ya eu autour de
l'iran bah on voit bien que à ce
débouché du golfe arabo persique et bien
il ya une grosse partie du trafic du
pétrole et du gaz
mais il y a aussi et c'est un point
extrêmement important le détroit de
malacca par lequel passe aujourd'hui
grosso modo 30 % du commerce mondial
or la question qu'on se peut se poser
chaque pourquoi le commerce maritime
mondial est il devenu si important est
ce que c'est pas le résultat de la
mondialisation
oui dans un certain sens oui c'est
absolument vrai et en fait on voit bien
que l'ampleur du commerce international
n'a cessé d'augmenter depuis 1971
jusqu'à grosso modo 2013 2014
alors on est passé de 15% à 30% après ce
qui est intéressant c'est que à partir
de 2013 2014
eh bien il ya une forme de stabilité et
ça prouve bien aussi qu'il y a là un
espèce de ralentissement que grosso modo
est bien le commerce mondial n'augmente
plus maintenant ce qui est aussi
extrêmement important c'est le
déplacement du commerce mondial vous
savez au moyen âge et à la renaissance
l'épicentre du commerce mondial c'était
la méditerranée puis à partir du xviie
jusqu'au xxème siècle ça a été l'océan
atlantique depuis la fin du xxème siècle
et le début du 21e siècle et bien les
choses se passent essentiellement en
asie et ce commerce mondial est
essentiellement maritime c'est ça oui
tout à fait et là c'est extrêmement
intéressant de voir que le volume du
commerce maritime
si on prend tous assis on prend à la
fois les liquides bon le pétrole les
ponts d re mais aussi tous les produits
qui circulent par bateau et bien ce
commerce a augmenté de plus de quatre
fois entre 1970 et 2010 neuf et désire
ce phénomène il ya une révolution une
révolution technique et technologique
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
conteneurisation et avec la
conteneurisation effectivement il est
devenu assez simple à ces pratiques de
faire circuler toute une série de
produits par voie maritime et la
conteneurisation a beaucoup joué dans
cette expansion générale du commerce
maritime et le rôle joué par les porte
conteneurs a donc augmenté
oui tout à fait alors ça c'est si vous
l'essayez c'est quelque chose qui est
allée de pair évidemment avec cette
révolution alors sur tout ce qui est
très impressionnant c'est
l'accroissement de la taille des porte
containers en 1970 on était encore sur
des navires de taille moyenne 27 mille
tonnes de jauge brute ça fait quand même
je vous signale un assez gros bateau bon
on avait vu cela se multiplier par deux
en 2009 65 à 90 puis encore par deux de
1990 à 2005 et on aboutit aujourd'hui à
un monstre comme les verts given qui est
donc qui était la cause du problème dans
le canal de suez ce qu'on appelle la
classe golden qui lui fait environ 220
milles tonneaux de jauge brute
alors évidemment ces navires sont de
plus en plus gros de plus en plus
puissants et donc de plus en plus
polluants pourquoi parce que leur
machinerie consomme presque
exclusivement de ce qu'on appelle du
fioul lourd autrement dit des résidus de
pétrole
ces résidus de pétrole sont très
dommageable en termes de particules
fines et en termes de co2 et il y a
énormément de bateaux on considère qu'il
y a grosso modo 6000 porte containers en
service dans le monde
sur ces six mille il y en a probablement
12 cents à pressante ils sont de très
gros porte conteneurs et des porte
containers géant
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire eh bien ça
veut dire que ce sont des bateaux qui
consomment beaucoup beaucoup de pétrole
a pratiquement 300 millions de tonnes et
si ces bateaux était un pays c'est la
scission ont décidé que leur
consommation de pétrole était celle d'un
pays et d une serait le 6
m pays du monde pour les rejets de gaz
polluants
alors jacques à quelles seraient les
solutions possibles dans ce cas alors
oui il ya plusieurs types de solutions
une première solution qui est déjà qui
compte déjà être mise en oeuvre en
particulier par la cgm la compagnie
d'armement française est bien c'est de
faire basculer les machineries de ces
énormes navires du fioul lourd vers le
gaz naturel liquéfié la cgm a mis en
service depuis deux trois ans plusieurs
navires qui fonctionne au gnl comme on
dit et c'est effectivement moins
polluants après l'autre principale
solution pour diminuer cette pollution
c'est de réduire le trafic est peut-être
d'utiliser d'autres voies ou d'autres
moyens de ce trafic
alors la russie qui évidemment a profité
de ce qui s'est passé sur le canal de
suez pour dire vous savez nous nous
avons la route maritime du nord qui
permettrait d'aller plus vite de
l'europe vers l'asie bien mais est ce qu
elle fait surtout avec la chine c'est de
développer désormais ce qu'on appelle la
voie à grande vitesse du transsibérien
il s'agit pas des 300 km heure comme le
tgv en france mais ça signifierait quand
même plus du doublement de la vitesse de
circulation des convois et donc des
marchandises des containers qui serait
chargée sur la côte sud de la chine
pourrait arriver au coeur de l'europe à
la frontière entre le bélarus et la
pologne en sept à huit jours c'est
grosso modo moitié moins de temps que ce
qu'il faut pour les transporter par
container et donc on pourrait décider de
décaler tout le trafic de choses
relativement urgente par cette voie et
ne garder finalement le trafic ne valent
que pour les marchandises très lourde et
pour lesquelles on veut prendre son
temps
1 comme par exemple les minerais ou le
pétrole mais jacques maintenant que le
canal
suez et débloquer tout va pouvoir
recommencer comme avant n'est ce pas
tout va pouvoir recommencer comme avant
je crois qu'il ya quand même eu une
prise de conscience alors d'abord il ya
une prise de conscience de la fragilité
du du commerce au naval parce que
l'accident qui a eu lieu la semaine
dernière
et bien cet accident des experts de la
circulation en aval n'avait cessé de
mettre en garde les différents
gouvernements contre ce risque
et puis donc il y à ce risque de
pollution ces bateaux il faut savoir
qu'un seul de ces bateaux consob disons
produit autant de pollution qu'un
million de voitures diesel aujourd'hui
et je le rappelle il y à plus de 1000 ou
de doute ce en suivant les sources
bateau énorme qui circulent
autrement dit on est sur une quantité de
pollution qui est très supérieure à
celle de la circulation automobile alors
oui je pense qu'il va falloir que nous
apprenions à réduire notre dépendance
vis-à-vis du commerce international pas
de ces commerces est bien entendu mais
de réduire notre dépendance et de
produire peut-être des choses plus local
ou plus régionale est en tous les cas de
réduire notre dépendance par rapport aux
transforma et hymne à longue distance